call it touch bar touch start touch bar
touch bar touch bar touch fire touch bar
the amazing new touch bar yep two words
touch bar
Alva believes this new touch screen
strip that lives above the keyboard on
its new MacBook Pros is the future of
laptops I'm not convinced just yet but
it is pretty cool the multi touch bar is
very responsive and the matte coating
feels very smooth to run your finger
across the coolest thing though
how shortcuts change depending on what
program you're in in an email window
you'll get text formatting options
including a rainbow bar for changing
colors in photos you'll get small
thumbnails of your shots and editing
options in Safari
you'll get shrunken tabs watching a
movie you'll get video controls but I
really do wonder how convenient it is to
keep moving your hands off the keyboard
and trackpad to go tap a small shortcut
on the other hand a dedicated emoji
strip we are living in amazing times
really useful though there's now a touch
ID fingerprint sensor in the power
button the laptop itself feels great the
new USBC port replace older monitor
cable and even power connections that
means you may need some adapters or
dongles good news there's still a
headphone port the keys on the keyboard
are flat now just like the MacBook I
won't lie it's going to take some
getting used to and the trackpad is
giant like you could sleep on this thing
the new MacBook Pro 13 inch with a touch
bar will start at $1,800 the 15 inch
with a touch bar starts at $2,400 stay
tuned for my full reviews of the laptops
in the meantime let's say it with them
touch bar touch Paw patch bar watch bar
talk bar just great thanks so much